en fait après roger 6 j'avais déjà vu
que tour à 5 gagner et donc j'allais
jouer torah 5 et puis je me suis aperçu
que j'avais beaucoup plus simple et que
voilà j'ai gagné tout de suite mais
après c'est sûr que
la position voyez je voyais très bien
quelle est ta gagnante
voilà c'est vrai que c'est toujours bien
de finir sur une jolie note mais c'était
pas le plus important le plus important
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment une
victoire on peut dire l'arraché mais
externe pour le moral pour faire simple
mais préparation n'ont pas n'ont pas
bien fonctionné ça ça m'a pas aidé
évidemment un
et après
voilà une fois qu'on se retrouve un peu
en difficulté c'est très difficile de
revenir et
voilà écrire également ne vais pas jouer
du tout à mon meilleur niveau
même en prenant pas en compte
les préparations qui sont pas tombés bon
forcément quand les préparations de
pompe à ce niveau c'est un gros handicap
mais en plus je me suis pas aidé par mon
niveau de jeu après ça a priori je me
suis trompé quand même dans ma
préparation même si j'avais regardé ça
ce matin ça n'a pas spécialement été
apparemment après la position semble
être dangereuse pour moi mais je pense
que ça tenait et que wladimir a trop
cherché à obtenir trop de la position
qu'il avait et on va dire que le vent a
commencé à tourner quand j'ai pu obtenir
mon contrat je accueil à ces cinq après
le pion à s'inquiète toujours un très
gros problème pour pour lui et je pense
que juste avant le 40e il a fauté après
l'opposition sans espoir romand en
pratique puisque c'est juste impossible
à défendre pour lui il faudrait une
précision extrême pour espérer faire
nulle et en corse et c'est loin d'être
acquis que la police ne soit pas juste
perdante
oui évidemment je suis impatient de
pouvoir rejouer à paris c'est vrai qu'on
avait un très beau tournoi déjà l'année
dernière et j'espère évidemment que ça
va bien se passer pour moi priori voilà
c'est un tournoi un peu plus fun parce
que c'est des parties rapides c'est un
peu plus décontracté
en même temps il ya un enjeu tout le
monde de prendre malgré tout l'événement
très au sérieux
voilà j'espère juste pouvoir m'amuser et
que les choses marchent mieux évidemment
à paris qui n ont marché jusque ici pour
moi